This episode is sponsored by Wren, a website
where you calculate your carbon emissions.
You can also sign up to make a monthly contribution
to offset your emissions or support rainforest
protection projects by clicking our link in
the description.
Tardigrades have been through a lot.
They’ve been sent to the moon.
They’ve had the moisture sapped out of them.
At times, they’ve been in extreme heat.
And at other times, they’ve had to contend
with extreme cold.
And they have borne this all with as much dignity
as a creature nicknamed “moss piglet”
can, not knowing that on the other side would
be a whole audience of scientists and microscopy
fans waiting to hear about the latest achievement
in tardigrade survival that they’ve managed to unlock.
Well, today, we’ve got a new one for you.
A harrowing journey for these tardigrades
that have taken them through, what we assume,
must be the worst thing that tardigrades have
yet been subjected to.
These poor, enduring tardigrades got stuck
in postal security.
Their journey through the macrocosmos began
in a much more idyllic place: a beach in Portugal.
These are marine tardigrades, which we’ve
never been able to show on our channel before
for the very simple reason that we’d never
found them before.
Sadly, there is not much information available
about marine tardigrades compared to freshwater
ones, so we won’t be able to dive too deep
into their lives today.
But we can watch their strange gecko-like
feet as they walk across the slide, and appreciate
that they are indeed very, very weird to look
at.
And James, our master of microscopes, had
been searching for marine tardigrades in the
various sand samples he gets from the Baltic
Sea.
But he couldn’t find any, perhaps because
the water wasn’t salty enough.
He’d even trawled through coral farm samples
to find them, but still no luck.
But then James reached out to a marine biologist
friend in Portugal named Maria and asked if
she could send some Portugal beach samples
along.
You know, the usual favors between friends.
So Maria went to the beach, following James’
instructions as she dug through the sand at
different phases of the tide, and gathered
algae and biofilm from the rocks.
Then she packed up the samples in a box,
and sent it in the mail.
Within that box, not yet known to either its
sender or receiver,
were these Batillipes tardigrades.
Batillipes is a genus of marine tardigrades.
And ironically, given how difficult they are
for James to find now, the first Batillipes
tardigrades were actually found in the Baltic
Sea, and since then there have been at least
36 species described.
We don’t know exactly what species these
Batillipes are, but they do strongly resemble
a species called Batillipes minius that was
discovered in northern Portugal in 2015.
And what was striking to James when he first
saw them is just how small they are.
He’d been expecting them to be so much larger,
more on the order of their freshwater relatives
like this one, which at 200x looks like a
giant compared to the Batillipes.
But James didn’t know that these adorable
little tardigrades were on route to him.
When Maria sent him those samples from the
beach, they were just hypothetical little
worlds teeming with unknown and unseen life.
And then those hypothetical little worlds
got stuck in Germany for security reasons.
Why?
No idea.
The microcosmos often has us shrugging and
saying, “We have no idea,”
to its many mysteries.
And I suppose that mirrors the reality of
the macrocosmos as well.
Because sometimes, you find out your package
full of beach sand is going to be stuck in
a German warehouse for the weekend, and all
you can do is shrug.
After someone opened up the package and checked
that everything had been declared correctly,
the package, and our tardigrades, were able
to resume their journey
and make it to James’ doorstep.
But unfortunately, the lack of oxygen meant
that the algae samples weren’t able to survive
their delay in the warehouse.
But that would never stop James from trying
to find whatever he can in his samples.
So he spent 16 straight hours
looking through them.
And to his delight, the sand samples had a
whole herd of Batillipes wandering around
in them, having survived a spectacular journey
they didn’t even know they were on.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren
for sponsoring this episode.
Wren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon emissions, then offset it by funding
projects like mineral weathering in Scotland
or providing clean burning fuel and cookstoves
for refugees in Uganda.
We’ll need a lot of different approaches
to stop the climate crisis, and this is just one
way that you can learn more about your carbon
contribution and take some action.
You’ll answer a few questions about your
lifestyle and they’ll also show you ways
you can start reducing your carbon emissions.
Now no one can reduce their footprint to zero,
but using Wren, you can help offset what you have left.
Once you sign up, you’ll receive updates
from the tree planting, rainforest protection,
and other projects you support.
And we’ve partnered with Wren to plant 10
additional trees for the first 100 people
who sign up using our link in the description!
The people on the screen right now are the
real heroes of this story except for, of course,
whoever was in Germany who decided that, yes,
indeed James could have his tardigrades.
Also the tardigrades are an additional hero
in this story, there's a lot of heroes, cause
there's a lot of stories.
But we are extremely grateful to those folks
right here.
They are our Patreon patrons, and if you want
to be a reason why this channel exists, you
can check it out at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.